their loved ones died in a setting that
was supposed to keep them safe
and for years they've been calling for
justice at chelmsford crown court today
they took an important step towards that
goal
their demonstrations outside followed by
a sentencing insight
that saw an nhs trust find one and a
half million pounds
for its failures to manage ligature
points involved in patients deaths
i'm left here bereaved i'm left here
angry and i'm left here with no justice
for my son if they'd listen to what
happened to my son
there's people that have died after him
that would still be alive
melanie leahy's son matthew is 20 when
he was found dead in his room at the
linden center in
an adult mental health center run by the
north essex partnership trust
he died from hanging in a room where
that shouldn't have been possible
lisa morris's son ben also died at the
linden center in 2008
another found dead after being placed in
its care
every time you think of a nice memory of
ben he's
tarnished with all this he's tarnished
with all the unanswered questions
he's um with not knowing the full truth
it's like a torture
the trust in question is now the essex
partnership university trust but in its
previous guise
11 of its patients died by hanging
between october 2004
and march 2015 a result the judge said
of its woefully inadequate risk
management
the court heard how each death was
investigated and each time
recommendations
made to reduce ligature risks but these
recommendations
were routinely ignored some fixtures
like door hinges and wardrobe handles
remained in place for up to nine years
after it was recommended they be removed
and in some cases the same
ligature point played a role in multiple
deaths
in a statement essex partnership
university trust apologized for the
failings and said it was fully committed
to ensuring that
every lesson is learned
for those still grieving though this
isn't where it ends they're now
demanding
a statutory public inquiry the whole
purpose of this journey is because i
want to know the truth as to how and why
my son died
and i still don't know it i need staff
interviewed under oath
so almost i go and the clear message to
the government is i'm not alone and
we're not
we're not going away more than 70
families share those demands
and they say they won't rest until they
are met however painful
the journey is ivor bennett sky news
chelmsford